bonjour sa fille la députée au travail
sur un front plus amicale que les
tranchées de la politique edouard la
vienne bonjour ça va bien oui ici elle
ne vient pas chercher des votes
elle suspend plutôt sa course à la
direction pour faire ce qu'elle fait
chaque année une demi douzaine de fois
depuis son entrée en politique
l'eau c'est la vie ça paraît banal
l'homme et sans eau on peut poser c'est
le sujet qu'elle a portée des années
quand bénévoles et qui lui a valu sa
place dans l'arène politique
j'ai choisi martine ouellette deux ans
après son élection en 2010 l'ingénieur
est catapulté ministre des ressources
naturelles
à nous de choisir ce que nous laissera
l'exploitation de nos richesses
naturelles
elle hérite de la réforme du régime
minier québécois avait pour principal
objectif d'augmenter les redevances
elle devient alors la cible des partis
d'opposition sont au delà des
sensibilités des intérêts il lui
reproche d'avoir ce mais l'incertitude
est plombé l'industrie minière
vous cherchez la meilleure façon de
reculer sur une première c'est les
chorales l'industrie en ahl les libéraux
tentent d'avoir sa tête ou encore des
jobs
alors quand est ce que la première
ministre va lui faire perdre sa job elle
déco comme le fiasco de gaz de schiste
on n'en veut plus au québec c'est clair
martin ouellette est une femme
déterminée pas du genre à se défiler
elle s'accroche cérémonie cha pas de la
politique par quelques mois je fais de
la politique parce que j'y crois je la
fais par conviction
elle est fière de ses réalisations comme
la fermeture de la centrale nucléaire de
gentilly nouvelle loi sur les mines
adopté à l'unanimité
c'est pas rien ça j'ai livré du côté de
l'éolien
ge et autres structures et l'éolien
parce qu'il y avait des excès des
libéraux généré politique
d'électrification des transports amorce
de modernisation du secteur forestier
madame walad bachand martin ouellette a
la conviction d'avoir contribué au
développement économique
mais entre convictions et rigidité il
n'ya souvent qu'un pas et à micro fermé
plusieurs collègues décrivent une femme
peut porter sur les compromis oui j'ai
travaillé en équipe et
et je trouve ça dommage que ce spin n'en
soit encore présent moi la première
mesure s'il accueille dix meilleurs
avoir des cours de français personne ne
remette en question sa ferveur
indépendantiste jeu définitivement la
plus classe du monde
un premier mandat sundown certains pans
d'ambivalence pour martine ouellette la
route vers l'indépendance doit être
clair chacun fait on analyse la dernière
campagne électorale
mais moi très clairement je pense que ce
qui nous ennuie le plus ça a été des
discours ambigu flou pour stopper le
déclin du pq elle propose un retour aux
sources
je crois qu'il faut absolument qu'elle
le parti québécois se ressentent se
ressemblent sur l'indépendance se
ressemblent sur la social démocratie
c'est ça l'identité du parti québécois
madame mère de deux enfants seule femme
dans la course
elle pense que même en 2015 être une
femme en politique comporte encore des
difficultés mais c'est comme si le fait
d'être sérieuse pour une femme c'était
moins pour ce tir que pour un autre
instant
dans son comté ont décrit une femme
impliquée et connus des électeurs de
tous les candidats à la succession de
paul et marois cette militante de longue
date est celle qui connaît le mieux le
parti québécois mois chauds parti
québécois depuis maintenant bien des
membres apprécient sa cohérence et la
force de ses convictions parti québécois
oui les chefs mes yeux les militants à
la base et la base le mois je peux vous
dire que la base que j'ai connu en 86 87
des années 90 c'est un peu la même chose
qu'aujourd'hui elle compte sur cette
base pour créer la surprise